The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, what
I thought I would do
is I'm going to go quickly
through the problems that
were assigned for practice.
There's seven or eight of them.
I'm not going to do all of them.
I'm going to go
through and kind of
talk about what some of the key
issues are with each problem
and maybe make some
points about identifying
how you do problems, not
necessarily specifically focus
on the exact question
that was asked here.
So here was this first-- this
was a quiz from last year.
And you were asked to
find an equation of motion
for this thing.
And it can be a bit
of a puzzling problem,
so how many degrees of freedom,
what are the constraints, what
equation should you use.
So first of all, I look
at a problem like this.
Is it planar motion or not?
OK, so maximum three
degrees of freedom.
What are the
constraints, though?
STUDENT: So G is [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So G is
R/2 from the center.
So that's true.
And so what you're really saying
is it's fixed in radial motion,
right?
And you're right.
So that's one constraint.
What's another constraint
in this problem?
How many degrees of freedom
do you expect to end up with?
How many equations do you need?
How many coordinates?
One, right?
So how do we articulate
the other constraint?
So it can't move radially.
We figured that out.
So this is actually kind
of an important point
in this problem.
Because if you
can get this down,
then the problem
becomes very simple.
So talk to a neighbor.
How would you describe
the other constraint here?
I'm going to hold it a second.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Pardon?
STUDENT: Gravity is
just [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well,
there is gravity, yes.
But gravity is not a constraint.
So this is a pendulum,
actually, of sorts.
So talk to a neighbor.
How would you describe
the other constraint?
OK, how would you describe it?
What's the other
constraint here?
So sometimes if
something is pinned,
we say, well, then
it's fixed in x and y.
And that's two constraints.
It's only left to rotate.
But this one doesn't seem
to-- it's kind of hard
to understand where
this one is pinned.
You know this thing is
constrained in x and y.
Because you want to use theta
for the coordinate, right?
But how do you say
that it's constrained
in that other thing?
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so he's
saying that you can define x
and y in terms of r and theta.
And that's true.
And I'm going to say it
slightly differently.
So the way I think
about this problem
is we've said that
it's constrained
in the radial direction.
So that's one.
It can move in the
tangential direction, right?
This problem is really
exactly the same
as the skateboard
problem in a bowl.
You shorten that
thing a little bit,
and it looks like a skateboard.
And we're ignoring the
inertia of the wheels.
So it's just a stick
sliding up and down.
So what's the relationship
between the tangential motion
and theta?
Is it a fixed relationship?
So how far does it
move in the theta?
If you have a little
motion, delta theta,
how far does it
move tangentially?
R delta theta is the
delta r tangential,
the distance it moves.
So this is the way to
say the other constraint,
is if you know theta,
you know how far it's
moved in the radial, in
the tangential direction.
So that's a way of saying
that other constraint.
OK, then we can say
we completely describe
this problem by one coordinate.
And that's theta.
And the second you can do
that, this problem then
has a center of rotation right
in the center of the circle.
And anytime you
have a body which
rotates around a
central point, then
you know that you can
describe the angular
momentum of the body
as some I with respect
to A times-- and
it's planar motion.
So then it's just omega z, as
long as this is a principal,
as long as you have the mass
moments of inertia in terms
of principal axes here.
And it's nice when you
can write it that simply.
The second you can identify
a fixed point about which
something rotates, then
the angular momentum
simplifies to that.
OK, and then this
problem, of course
the sum of the torques
with respect to the center
here has got to be d H with
respect to A dt plus vAO
cross PGO.
But this is-- what's
the velocity at point A?
0, so you don't have to
worry about this term.
And it's just that.
And you know that the sum
of the external torques
in this problem
comes from gravity.
So you put in the gravity
term and compute the torques
about the center.
So our object really
looks like that.
And here's G. And in the
problem, the way it was posed,
the theta is drawn
from this line.
So this is theta.
So what's the moment arm?
It looks like whatever this
distance is, which is R/2.
It's given.
R/2 cosine theta is the
length of this side.
So the moment that
gravity makes is some Mg.
And that's going to
be equal to some Izz
about A theta double dot.
OK, good.
Let's take a look
at the next problem.
And now so my
intention here, I'm
going to go kind of
quickly one by another.
And I'm just trying to hit
the important concepts.
So if you have a question
about the concepts, ask.
If I've left you
wondering, I really
want this to be kind
of a conversation here.
So that's the whole point.
I've given you the essence of
what makes these problems work.
OK, this one, we just find a
location of the center of mass.
I think you're pretty good
at that sort of thing.
Well, remember just a couple
points about center of mass.
This one it says, find it.
And you're given
the two objects.
The important point
is that you can
pick any coordinate
at all in order
to use it to compute
the center of mass.
So I pick S here, the M1.
And some distance down here
is where the center of mass
is that we're looking for.
And so this is the
G we're looking for.
So M1 plus M2 is the total
mass times the position of G.
I guess that ought to
be a capital-- SG here
must be equal to the sum of the
parts times their positions, M1
SG1 plus M2 SG2.
And you can solve for SG.
And that tells you
where you're at.
So you can pick any coordinate
at all to calculate it.
And once you find it,
you know where it is.
So you just solve here for SG.
It's that divided by the
total mass, obviously.
OK, the next question
was, draw principal axes.
So does this object have
some planes of symmetry?
Tell me one.
STUDENT: This one.
PROFESSOR: Slice down
through it this way, OK.
And that means you have
a principal axis where?
Perpendicular to every
plane of symmetry.
So you have a principal axis
coming out of the board.
That's one.
And give me another
plane of symmetry.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, this one.
So that means you've
got a plane of axis,
principal axis going that way.
And so then the third one has
to be perpendicular to that.
So you have one this way,
this way, and this way.
So I'd asked for-- so if this
is G, then principal axes
with respect to G, one there,
one coming out of the board,
and one going up like that.
So what is it?
Let's remind ourselves what it
means to be a principal axis.
So if you know the
principal axes of an object,
if you rotate, and you've
chosen them to go through G,
do they have to go through G?
Do all principal axes
have to go through G?
No, not at all.
The principal axes just have to
give you, when you work it out,
a diagonal inertia matrix.
But what does it
mean to have body
coordinates that we
know are principal axes?
Well, one of the things we know,
that if you rotate about G,
rotate about a principal
axis passing through G,
if you rotate about
any one of them,
is it dynamically balanced?
Guaranteed.
You must rotate about the
principal axis, though.
Now, I'll ask you
a second question.
If you rotate about any
axis passing through G,
is it statically balanced?
Right, if you rotate about
any axis passing through G,
is it dynamically balanced?
Maybe, right?
Not necessarily.
It might be dynamically
balanced if you pass through G,
and it is a principal
axis, right?
OK, can you have a principal
axis not going through G
and rotate about
that axis and have
it be dynamically balanced?
Yeah, OK, so we'll talk
about an example in a second.
OK, so I think the second
question here said,
OK, we want to rotate
this about this point G2.
Now, G2 is right in the
middle at this body.
That's where its
center of mass is.
And there's a G1 up here
that's the center of mass
of the upper body.
And there's a composite
center of mass right
here, which we just
computed what it was.
And we want-- there's going to
be an axis of rotation passing
through G2.
And we're rotating
this body around it.
So first question is, this
axis coming through G2,
is it a principal axis?
Yes.
If we rotate about
that axis only,
do you expect it to be
dynamically balanced?
Right.
Do you expect it to be
statically balanced?
No.
So we're spinning it around this
G2, going like that around G2
at some omega z.
We know that this is G2.
We know that G for
the object is here.
That's the center of
mass of the whole thing.
So there's some distance between
those two, which I don't know.
But we could figure it out.
We'll call it e.
So what's the force
required at this pin
that its axle is going around?
What's the force required
to allow this thing
to spin around, to hold it,
essentially, the force required
to hold it in place?
And you ought to intuitively
have an idea of what it is.
Why is there a force?
That thing will spin
around this central axle.
And there's a force
required to keep
that thing from moving away.
What is it?
STUDENT: Centrifugal force.
PROFESSOR: I hear centrifugal.
So you're accelerating the
center of mass of that thing.
You're making it go in a circle.
Mass times acceleration
is a force.
And that's the tension
in the string when you're
swinging the ball around.
This is no different from
swinging the ball on a string.
And you're essentially
calculating
the tension required to keep
that thing from flying off.
And we could
probably just guess.
We can almost guess what it
is, minus the total mass times
the acceleration,
which is inward.
That's where the
minus comes from.
And what is it?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Louder.
PROFESSOR: Omega squared.
I hear an omega z squared.
We need something else.
Pardon?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah, the r.
And the r is this little e here.
It's called the
eccentricity, when
you have something
unbalanced. e omega squared,
and it's in the r hat direction.
We'll call it inwards.
And the inwards is the minus.
So that's the acceleration.
Mass times acceleration
is the force.
Also, you could compute this
by computing d by dt of P of G
with respect to
O. And that's then
M1 plus M2 times v of G. You
have to take the d by dt of it.
And that gives you that,
which is the acceleration.
So the forces you get
directly from computing dP/dt,
if you need to remember
a way to do that.
All right, so conceptually,
if I don't know what e is,
then I don't want to
have to figure it out.
So I'm going to describe to
you a way in which you could
get directly at
this answer, which
reminds us something
about angular
momentum and these bodies.
This object is made
up of two objects.
And we're spinning it about
the center of one of them.
So let's take them
one at a time.
How much force is required
to keep this spinning
about that axle that goes right
through its center of mass?
None, right?
Because there's no
r omega squared.
There's no acceleration.
You're not making the center
of mass of this object
go in a circle.
So this piece doesn't
enter into the solution.
The actual force, the
mass, this mass here,
is M2 in the problem.
M2 doesn't actually have
anything to do with the answer.
Because it's
perfectly statically
balanced around that point.
All of this force making
the thing go in a circle
is making this piece
go in a circle.
So in fact, this force
up here is minus M1.
And now we need the distance
from the axis of rotation
to its center of mass.
Well, that's some r.
We need to know what that r is.
And I think that's
basically-- this was L/2.
And this was b, so plus b/2.
So the distance from
this rotation point
to that center of mass is L/2
plus b/2, omega z squared.
Mass-- this is acceleration,
and it's inwards.
And that's the total force.
All right, let's look
at the next problem.
Vicente, can you
pull up the next one?
OK, this problem-- this
problem and the next
are rather similar.
This is the elevator
problem with the pendulum
in the elevator.
There's a couple
subtleties here.
The elevator, you're told
that it's moving upwards
at some particular
rate of acceleration,
some y double dot.
That's given.
So how many degrees of freedom
does this problem have?
OK, two or one?
I hear one.
I see a two.
How many coordinates
is it going to take
to completely
describe the motion,
or how many equations
of motion do
you think you're going to need?
I see ones and twos.
So there's a little
not-- two, OK.
If we know the acceleration
of the thing-- we start
with some initial
conditions, at time 0,
it's sitting on the
ground, and y equals 0,
and now it takes off
from the first floor-- we
know for all time its position.
So that's actually a given.
It's a specified thing.
And we don't have to write a
separate equation of motion
for that that we then
will have to solve.
So it's actually given.
So the actually only
dynamic equation
of motion we have to write
is about the pendulum.
Now, will it involve
y double dot?
Absolutely.
But it's a given number.
It's just a number you're given.
You don't have to write a
separate equation of motion.
So actually you've got
just one degree of freedom.
Yeah.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so put up
the next problem-- that one.
So this problem has how
many degrees of freedom?
This is definitely two.
Because you don't know.
The motion in the up
and down of the mass
and the slider with a
spring on it is unknown.
You're going to have to write
an equation of motion, which
would have to be solved to
get it, so a distinction,
a subtlety that can trip you up.
When the motion is
actually specified,
and you know what
it is for all time,
you don't need a separate
equation for that.
So this problem requires two.
The behavior of
the pendulum part
is essentially the same in both.
When you write the equation--
well, let's talk about it.
How will we go about
solving this problem?
We need two equations,
two coordinates.
What would you pick
for your coordinates?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Theta, and
then a coordinate.
This one I guess
is called y, so y
for the square block
sliding up and down,
and a theta for the pendulum,
two equations of motion.
And to get the y
equation of motion,
you would use-- we're
not using Lagrange here.
We're going to do a little
review of direct method.
How would you write the equation
of motion using-- up there
I kind of wrote the
key to everything
that we do with the direct
method, some of the forces,
some of the torques.
Every rigid body has at max
how many degrees of freedom?
Six for rigid body.
In planar motion, this
is reduced to three.
But every rigid
body in 3D space has
six degrees of freedom-- three
positions, three rotations.
So you write some of
the forces on the body.
That is equal to the
mass times acceleration.
That gives you three equations,
one in each vector, component
direction.
You write the sum
of the torques.
That's also a vector equation.
You can get as many as
three equations out of it
if you need it.
Then we keep reducing
down how many
equations we need to get by
figuring out the constraints
until we get down to the number
of actual degrees of freedom.
And that's the remaining
equations, the number
of equations you actually need.
So this one requires two.
And if you're going to
write an equation of motion
about the main mass that slides
up and down, what law would
you use?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
sum of the forces
equal to the mass
times acceleration.
Then we need to get
another question.
What law would you use
for the second one?
STUDENT: Torque.
PROFESSOR: Torque about where?
STUDENT: A.
PROFESSOR: Torque about
A. So let's look at that.
So that's the second
equation up there.
Torque about A is
the time derivative
of the angular momentum
with respect to A plus
that vA cross momentum
term, which is
a little annoying to work out.
So the simpler version
is the third equation.
It's a pretty quick derivation
to go from that second equation
to the third.
And it's much less
work, generally,
to get that mass
times acceleration
term, a lot less work actually.
And if I've got
time, I'll go back
and we'll work out
a problem like this.
And we'll do that part.
But let's go on to
the other questions.
OK, this problem--
two rigid bodies.
Is it planar motion?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Right?
How many possible degrees of
freedom for each rigid body?
Times 2, 6, now how
many constraints?
So let's take them one
rigid body at a time.
It's a big roller.
Pardon?
STUDENT: No y.
PROFESSOR: No y, she says.
OK, that's one constraint
in it-- two left,
two possible things left.
STUDENT: No slip.
PROFESSOR: Ahh, so I
think this one's no slip.
So how does a no slip then
give you a constraint?
STUDENT: So x dot equals r
omega of the wheel turning.
PROFESSOR: So r, there's an r.
X equals r theta,
or minus r theta
depending on how you
define the theta, right?
So x is not
independent of theta.
And that's a second constraint.
So you only need one equation,
one generalized coordinate,
to describe the
motion of the wheel.
And what would you use?
STUDENT: Theta?
PROFESSOR: OK, theta.
You could use theta.
Or you could use x.
All right, and now the other
object, how many constraints
does it have?
And what are they?
What are the constraints
on the T bar?
STUDENT: Can't translate the y.
PROFESSOR: OK, that's true.
Let me give you a little
hint about how I process
this when I'm looking at it.
Remember when you're picking
generalized coordinates,
they need to be independent.
And independent means if
you freeze all but one,
that last one can still move.
OK, so we've picked one.
You said theta or x.
Let's freeze it.
What motion is
left of that T bar?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: It can
only rotate, right?
And that means it
has a pin, a point
about at which it rotates,
which you have just fixed.
So it's constrained.
That pin constrains it
in how many directions?
STUDENT: Two.
PROFESSOR: Two,
right off the bat.
You have the two constraints
right at the pin.
But it's not so obvious
until you say, let's freeze
at other coordinates.
And then we see
that, ahh, there's
only one possible motion
left, the rotation.
OK, so we have a rotation and a
translation, or two rotations.
That's the way we could
write equations of motion.
If we did translation
of the main disk,
what equation would you use to
write the equation of motion
for the main disk?
STUDENT: Force.
PROFESSOR: Force, yeah.
Newton's second law, sum of
the forces in what direction?
It can only move in--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Horizontal, yeah.
So sum of the forces
in the x direction,
sum of external forces
equals mass times acceleration.
Now this, though, has some
problematic external forces,
right?
What are they, the
difficult ones?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, friction.
There's a friction force.
And there's also the
internal forces at the pin.
So you're going to
have to sort out how
to work your way through that.
If you don't want to mess with
external forces at the pin,
you have to sum
rotations at the--
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
so this problem,
there's no escaping
something messy.
So let's say one
equation will be
the sum of the forces
on that main roller
in the horizontal direction.
And that's going to force
us to deal with a friction
force and an internal, two
reaction forces at the pin.
Well, you just write them down.
Then go and write the same
expression, sum of the forces
on the other object.
And it'll also show up with
those two internal forces.
You add those two
equations together.
Those forces cancel.
And that gives you
the first equation.
And it'll involve
acceleration of both masses.
And you'll have to figure
out the acceleration
of that second mass
around its own.
But you know how to do that.
That's just kinematics.
And then you've got to
do the torque equation.
And you'd probably
do it about A.
And does this involve--
what about the velocity of A
in this problem?
Is it 0?
No, so you may have to
deal with that second term.
And again, I would go
use the third expression.
Because you need to find
the accelerations anyway.
And I would use that.
Yeah.
STUDENT: Could you also take
the sum of the torques about d?
PROFESSOR: Some of
the torques about?
STUDENT: d?
PROFESSOR: Then d is
the point of contact.
Yeah, and that would give
you a way of getting at,
I think, an equation
of motion that mostly
describes the big roller.
I don't know.
In terms of the
other one, I'm not--
summing it, then talking
about the second rigid body?
I don't think I would do it.
It gets a little complicated.
But it's interesting.
It might be worth a try.
I'd probably do it about A,
is the point I would choose,
and deal with the
fact that you need
to know the acceleration
of A. But in this problem,
that's pretty straightforward.
What's the acceleration
of point A?
And let's say our
horizontal coordinate is x.
What's the acceleration
of point A?
x double dot in the I
direction-- pretty easy
to stick that in this
third expression up here.
And you know Rg
with respect to A
is just the length
of the distance down
to the center of mass of
that T. So that term's
pretty easy to figure out.
And then the lead term is just
everything with respect to g.
And that's pretty
straightforward.
OK, good, how are
we doing on time?
Not a lot left.
And is that the last problem?
Yeah.
STUDENT: Quick question.
The previous problem, we don't
need to worry about friction,
do we?
STUDENT: If it was
slipping, we would.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, will
friction ultimately
end up in the
answer to this one?
No.
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, speaking
in Lagrange terms,
does it do any work?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: I know, but you
know about it now, right?
Constraints that
do no work usually
don't end up in
the final answer.
I don't have a simple way of
explaining why it doesn't.
But if in the first case,
instead of doing Newton's law
on the first one, we had
done torques about d,
it would have given us
an equation of motion
for the roller.
And then you could
have done torques
about A, a different equation.
And we'd have got an equation
of motion largely dealing
with T. You still have
some internal forces
and torques that you're
going to have to eliminate.
So this is not a simple problem,
but straightforward if you
know what laws to apply to
some of the forces, some
of the torques.
And be careful with
the extra term.
If this object were just
given an initial deflection,
like the T bar is picked up and
let go, and it's just there,
and it's just doing
its thing, what
can you say about the center
of mass of the system?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Well, it's not that
it doesn't necessarily move.
Well, let's put it this way.
What if I gave this thing
a push to start with,
and now it's going
to roll along?
Huh?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, in
that case, you're
saying that the center of mass
moves with constant velocity.
And Newton would agree with you.
Why?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Because once
it gets rolling, is there
any friction force?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: So you've got to
draw the free body diagram
and decide whether or not there
are any forces on the system.
If there are no external
forces on the system,
Newton says no acceleration,
no change in momentum.
So once you get it
rolling, there's
actually no friction force.
Because it isn't trying to
either speed up or slow down
the rolling.
So it goes actually to 0.
Is there slip?
No, it still isn't slipping.
But it's just happily
rolling along.
There are no external
forces acting on it.
It means the mass times the
acceleration of the center
of mass of the system is zero.
So the center of mass
does not accelerate.
That means it has
constant velocity.
Now, if I contrive to have the
initial velocity of the center
of mass be 0, just cause that
thing to swing back and forth,
what would you see
the center of mass do?
It has no linear momentum.
The linear momentum
of the system is 0.
So the center of
mass sits still.
Its velocity now is 0.
There's still no acceleration.
It's just this T bar is
rocking back and forth.
So what must the
roller be doing?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: So the roller
has to move to the left
when the T bar is
going to the right.
So the two things
are going like this.
In the center of mass, wherever
it is, it's just sitting still.
All right, is there
a last problem?
This forces you to go back
to the fundamental definition
of angular momentum.
It's R cross, this little
summation of each RI cross PI.
And add them up, and you get the
angular momentum with respect
to the rotational point,
1 degree of freedom,
has a center of mass.
Where is the center
of mass of the system?
Can you describe it?
STUDENT: Right in between--
PROFESSOR: Somewhere in
between the two masses.
There are two point
masses, center mass
has to be someplace in between.
So once you figure out
where that is, then
you can concentrate all the
mass there and go from there.
Does this have mass
moment of inertia?
Can you write the
equation of motion?
This is a pendulum.
Can you write I about A theta
double dot equals minus Mg
something sine theta?
This is a pendulum.
The restoring torque on
it comes from gravity.
And you'll end up
with an expression
that looks like
some I with respect
to the point of rotation.
So basically, you just
need to figure out
what is I with respect to
A. And they're particles.
So each particle has an I with
respect to its center of mass.
It's equal to, for a particle,
concentrated point mass?
STUDENT: Mr squared?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
but there's no r.
So I for a particle about
its center mass is 0.
So this only has parallel
axis theorem components.
It has M1 times this
distance squared
from the center plus M2
times this distance squared
from the center.
And that's the total Izz.
So then you can write it out.
OK, so I think we've
run out of time.